was meint ihr wie viele Länder kann ich
in 24 Stunden bereisen diese Challenge
kam mir letztens in den Kopf es gibt
eigentlich keine Regeln ich darf fliegen
Zug autoahren meinet wegen mir sogar
einen privaten Chauffeur buchen und mal
sehen vielleicht packe ich am Ende ja
wirklich über Z Länder da ich aber
außerdem drei Youtuber herausfordern
möchte um mich eventuell zu schlagen ist
das einzige was ich vorgebe starte von
deiner Wohnung oder deinem Büro aus und
berühre das jeweilige Land bzw ein
Gebäude in dem Land wirklich mit deinen
Füßen viel Spaß so leute es ist
5:55 Uhr und Zeit läuft ab
jetzt und damit einen wunderschönen
guten Morgen aus Köln auf den Straßen
ist doch nicht so viel los wir haben ja
auch ziemlich früh und Leute heute
starten wir ein neues Experiment ich
werde versuchen in 24 Stunden so viele
verschiedene Länder wie möglich zu
bereisen irgendwie ist mir diese Idee
mal in Kopf gekommen und ich dachte mir
ich will das einfach machen ich will
daraus a so eine kleine Challenge machen
und später dann noch andere Youtuber
rausfordern die mich dann eventuell
schlagen können wenn sie halt gut sind
aber ich bin ja mittlerweile sehr Reise
erfahren und ich glaube wir werden auf
jeden Fall acht bis 12 Länder schaffen
heute je nachdem ich habe überlegt ob
ich irgendwelche Spielregeln aufstelle
oder sonst was aber wir lassen das
komplett also man ist komplett frei man
kann Bus Bahn Autofahren meine wegen
sogar auch fliegen werde ich denke ich
auch machen wir werden mal gucken was am
schlaustusten ist ich habe natürlich
schon eine kleine rutee im Kopf das
einzige was ich als kleine Vorgabe geben
würde wenn das am Ende wirklich ein
anderer Youtuber nachmacht und versucht
mich zu schlagen man muss entweder von
seiner Wohnung aus starten oder von
seinem ü ich habe jetzt halt wieder ein
Büro hier in Köln seit zwei Monaten und
ich war jetzt eh in Köln und deswegen
starte ich auch von hier also ich mache
mich jetzt gerade auf dem Weg zum Kölner
Hauptbahnhof und dann geht's von dort
erstmal in die Niederlande nach Belgien
Luxemburg Schweiz ich habe keine Ahnung
wir werden mal schauen ich habe noch
nichts gebucht wir machen das komplett
Freestyle und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
Spaß mit dem Video ihr könnt ja gerne
jetzt schon mal kommentieren was ihr
denkt wie viel ich am Ende schaffe ich
bin selber ultra gespannt ich weiß aber
es wird ein verdammt langer Tag ich habe
theoretisch bis nächsten Morgen um 6 Uhr
Zeit ach so den ersten Stop weiß ich
schon das wird aen sein und von da aus
geht's dann weiter nach Holland und ja
dann schauen wir
mal ich glaube das letzte Mal um diese
Uhrzeit in Köln war ich als ich hier
selber noch gewohnt habe und vorher
feiern war schaut mal Leute es fängt do
schon super an 25 Minuten Verspätung
diesen Zug wollte ich nehmen jetzt kann
ich da noch 25 Minuten irgendwo
rumhängen ich bin jetzt gerade auf der
Einkaufsstraße hier bin ich heute morgen
aufgewacht deswegen Länder Counter 1 ja
läuft doch gut oder schaut mal Leute und
hier haben wir auch schon den Dom und da
hinten ist auch der Hauptbahnhof ich
habe ja schon gesagt ich werde auf auf
jeden Fall drei Youtuber nominieren zwei
weiß ich schon weil man muss ja auch ein
bisschen nachdenken wer könnte das
wirklich machen sowas macht auch nicht
jeder ist ja schon ziemlich anstrengt
und man muss einfach mal die Komfortzone
verlassen ich habe schon zwei im Kopf
ein dritter oder eine dritte ist mir
noch nicht eingefallen aber ich überlege
noch ein bisschen und am coolsten W
natürlich wenn es alle umsetzen und
schauen wer nachher am besten ist aber
ich will natürlich gut vorlegen ab in
[Musik]
Hauptbahnhof so kurz ein bisschen
Frühstück geholt und auf geht's zum
Gleis Gleis neun nach aen 20 Minuten
warten schaut mal Leute auch interessant
die taleszüge wurden jetzt von Eurostar
übernommen den habe ich ja mal getestet
aber normalerweise stand da ja Tales
drauf und jetzt halt Eurostar weil die
normalen Eurostar Züge sehen ja auch
anders aus na ja darum geht's heute ich
habe gerade sogar kurz überlegt ob es s
mach diesen Zug zu nehmen weil der fährt
bis Paris durch aber er fährt nicht
durch Holland sonst hätte ich das
gemacht weil von Paris wä ich dann
einfach irgendwo wieder hingeflogen aber
ich glaube ich ma meine Route die ich
mir so im Kopf vorgeplant habe ist den
[Musik]
schlauer okay Leute angekommen achen
hier bin ich schon mal ich bin fast in
Holland das ist nicht mehr weit 4 km
noch oder 5 ich muss mich jetzt richtig
beeilen weil ich will jetzt einmal kurz
nach Holland fahren mit Taxi oder uber
dann wieder zurück und dann von hier aus
nach Belgien weiterzu fahren mein Zug
hatte halt leider eine halbe Stunde
Verspätung aber wo stehen jetzt hier die
Taxen diger hä eigentlich hätte ich es
mit Zug gemacht aber das schaffe ich
jetzt nicht mehr sonst kriege ich halt
mein ICE nicht der halt mich
weiterbringt und ich muss ja schnell
denken ne nur nach Holland W nach
Holland einfach nur an die Grenze und
wieder hier zurück aber welche Grenze am
besten so schnell wie möglich wissen s
da was hauptgrenze ja genau dass ich
einmal in Holland bin und dann muss ich
hier da musst du einmal kurz über die
Grenze und dann direkt quasi wieder
zurück genau richtig mach so ein
videoagebuch darüber ach so das war's
schon dann also das Youtube ja ich will
heute so viele Länder wie möglich
schaffen in 24 Stunden kommt ihr gleich
schon die Grenze wir fahren auf die
Autobahn und dann Benze okay Stadion was
ging nach der Brücke ah geil da passen
ja auch 30.000 oder so rein ne sieht
eigentlich eher aus wie ein bundeslig
Stadion anstatt vierte Liga ne übrigens
wenn ihr euch für Fußball interessiert
checkt gerne mal meinen anderen Kanal ab
abonniert den gerne da kommen so travel
Videos in Verbindung mit Fußball ist in
der Videobeschreibung verlinkt jetzt
gleich sind wir in Holland ja erkennt
man direkt an der Autobahn auch ne das
anderes Land ist und jetzt
Geschwindigkeitsreduzierung übrigens
habe ich mich dann doch nicht nach achen
zum Bahnhof zurückbringen lassen sondern
nach herlen wir waren nämlich schon
ziemlich nah dran und dort gibt's auch
ein Bahnhof und zu der Zeit war
Berufsverkehr und ziemlich großes
Verkehrs aufkommen ich glaube es gibt so
eine Spiegel TV Doku über herlin wo die
dann immer mit den Autos rüber fahren
und dann die Automaten hochjagen so
Leute ich bin h auf jeden Fall gerade in
herlen ich muss hier noch Geld abheben
um das Taxi zu bezahlen und hier aus
herlen kommen die ganzen
automatensprenger aber dieser Automat
hier steht noch ich glaube deswegen
kommen die auch nach Deutschland weil
man den wahrscheinlich nicht sprengen
kann ne sieht aber soweit ganz schön aus
und lers stop Nummer 2 auch abgehakt ich
bin in Holland weiter geht's
Anschlusszug habe ich verkackt aber mal
gucken wie es weitergeht irgendwie muss
ich jetzt nach Belgien okay weiter
geht's ab zum Gleis also das sieht hier
wirklich alles top mododern aus ach das
ist der Bahnhof okay ich bin jetzt auf
jeden Fall ein bisschen außerplanmäßig
in herlen angekommen herin ist die Stadt
in den Niederlanden mit der höchsten
Kriminalitätsrate das meinte auch der
Taxifahrer zu mir ich muss noch kurz
Werbung für ihn machen habe ich ihn
versprochen also wenn ihr aus Aachen
kommt spartaxi aen hier hier kommen auf
jeden Fall diese ganzen
automatenspringer und so her ist ja auch
direkt an der Grenze ich stehe jetzt
hier das ist ja auch ganz wichtig einmal
das Land mit den Füßen zu berühren und
nicht nur irgendwie durchzufahren von
hier aus geht's auf jeden Fall jetzt
weiter nach Belgien und ja kurzes
zeitupdate wir haben jetzt 8:25 Uhr ich
bin einfach schon seit 2 Stunden 30 Uhr
unterwegs das kommt mir eigentlich eher
so vor als wäre ich er seit einer Stunde
unterwegs das Reisen vergt echt immer so
schnell eine Sache wollte ich noch
gesagt haben und zwar gibt es ja
wirklich eigentlich keine Regeln für
dieses Format also falls es jemand
nachmachen sollte ihr müsst nur einfach
mit dem Fuß auf dem jeweiligen Land
stehen und bei euch in der Wohnung oder
im Büro starten weil sonst könnte man
sich ja direkt an irgendeine länderecke
beamen und dann direkt drei Länder
machen das wäre halt vielleicht bisschen
unfair ich hatte nämlich noch überlegt
eventuell so eine budgetvorgabe zu
setzen dass man halt nur 500 € ausgeben
kann aber ich dachte mir falls es
irgendjemand nachmacht ich will dass ihr
dann kreativ seid euch meintweggen auch
keine Ahnung privates Shuttle was weiß
ich Buch um mir halt gegebenfalls
Konkurrenz zu machen deswegen auch keine
budgetvorgabe man kann so viel
ausgeehben wie man will ich bin noch mal
gespannt ich werde auf jeden Fall später
noch ich denke von Basel nach Wien
fliegen weil das sonst einfach so eine
Weide Strecke ist oder vielleicht auch
nach Budapest um halt wirklich noch
viele Länder abzuhaken es wird auf jeden
Fall noch ein richtig stressiger und
langer Tag aber ich habe Bock und wir
warten jetzt auf den nächsten Zug ey
Leute ich bin wirklich so sauer ne es
läuft gerade alles schief was hätte
schieflaufen können mein erster Zug hat
ja eine halbe Stunde Verspätung deswegen
habe ich dann das Taxi genommen weil ich
dachte geht schneller und dann bin ich
in Herden rausgesprungen wollte dann
schnell mit der Regel wieder nach aen
fahren um dann weiterzukommen und sobald
man in Deutschland ist ja in den
Niederlanden war alles pünktlich sobald
du in Deutschland über die Grenze bist
ist wieder Verspätung schon wieder 15
Minuten Verspätung weshalb ich dann mein
Anschlusszug verpasst habe nach lüttigch
und das Dumme ist warte mal ich habe
diesen Scheiß Zug Eurostar wä das
gewesen für 38 € gebucht obwohl das nur
20 Minuten Fahrt wäre und jetzt stehe
ich hier im Regen und habe ja bin schon
vier Stunden unterwegs gleich und habe
gerade mal Niederlande und Deutschland
[Musik]
man ich bin jetzt angekommen in
welkenreed es ist zwar ziemlich
regnerisch und es sieht auch sehr grau
aus aber das hier ist belgi somit Land
Nummer 3 ich bin gerade einfach in
irgendein Zug gesprungen weil ich
einfach nur aus Deutschland raus wollte
die Züge komplette Verspätung wieder
katastrophal es war ein absoluter Fehler
bei diesem Projekt die ersten zwei
Stunden auf die Deutsche Bahn zu
vertrauen kannst du komplett vergessen
also ohne die wäre ich jetzt schon viel
viel weiter na ja ich muss jetzt schauen
dass ich von hier aus nach Lüttig komme
und von Lüttig dann weiter nach
Luxemburg das ist jetzt der Plan den
werde ich auch versuchen einzuhalten und
das beste ist aber gerade ich habe nicht
mal ein Ticket also weil ich kann das
Ticket nicht buchen für die Züge die
jetzt fahren geht irgendwie nicht mehr
einfach freundlich sein damit komme ich
eigentlich immer durch
ich bin angekommen l bzw l da wärden
erinnerungwach an meine Fahrradreise
nach Paris da bin ich irgendwo da hinten
lang geeiert mit dem Fahrrad ja und
jetzt geht's weiter in den IC für den
ich auch kein Ticket buchen konnte nach
Luxemburg also ich habe jetzt immer noch
kein Ticket versuche jetzt mal ein
Schaft da zu finden D der mir eins
verkauft das ist irgendwie total komisch
man kann online keine Tickets mehr
buchen ich kann mich natürlich auch aus
mit den verschiedenen barnaps aber es
geht nicht so dann wollen wir mal hier
rein da hinten ist ein Schaffner also
ich sitze jetzt zhal Stunden in diesem
Zug ich habe jetzt den Schaffner gefragt
so jo ich kann das Ticket nicht buchen
und ich hatte das schon paar Mal wenn
man im Ausland nett fragt so zumindest
war es bei mir malmer so hier kommt halt
immer eine Fehlermeldung zack um habe
ich ihm gezeigt er so alles gut geh rein
ist schon cool also in Deutschland habe
ich solche Erfahrung noch nicht gemacht
leider trotzdem ist Deutschland
natürlich mein Lieblingsland was den
Schienenverkehr angeht bin ich leider
nicht so happy ich habe dann weiter
geplant und habe einen Zug von Luxemburg
über Zürich nach Wien gefunden
allerdings schon um 14:55 Uhr das heißt
ich hätte maximal 45 Minuten in
Luxemburg gehabt und mit Boarding hätte
ich den wahrscheinlich gar nicht
bekommen deswegen habe ich so ein
flextarif gebucht und habe den Flug dann
später noch auf ein bisschen später
abends
[Musik]
gelegt okay Leute Land hier ich befinde
mich in Luxemburg ich muss sagen ich bin
auch zum allerersten Mal im Land
Luxemburg und jetzt in der Hauptstadt
die ja auch Luxemburg heißt sieht auf
jeden Fall ganz schön aus ich werde mir
kurz was zu Essen hier holen weil ich
habe übelst Hunger ich habe schon
gesehen mein Flug den würde ich jetzt
niemals packen deswegen habe ich den ein
bisschen weiter nach hinten verschoben
da geht nämlich noch einer wir gehen
jetzt erstmal was essen und schauen uns
kurz ducksburg an ich habe ungefähr eine
dreiviertel Stunde hier Zeit oder eine
Stunde dann muss ich weiter aber Essen
gehört halt auch dazu man will ja nicht
verhungern ich habe auch gerade mal
gegoogelt hier leben einfach nur 132 000
Menschen sieht eigentlich auf dem ersten
BCK deutlich größer aus Leute ich bin
auf jeden hier besten burgerlad in
Luxemburg sieht auf jeden Fall richtig
lecker aus ihr kennt mich ja burer
immer danke für den Drink habe ich
einach Geschenk
bekommen also Leute hier Burger BRs in
Luxemburg sehr sehr leckerer Burger hat
mich so ein bisschen an so richtig aber
richtig guten wenburger von früher
erinnert aber halt in richtig gut also
falls ihr hier mal seid checkt das doch
mal aus aber wir machen uns jetzt auf
dem Weg nach Frankreich da ich mein Flug
nämlich jetzt auf 19 Uhr gelegt habe
also relativ spät abends kann ich noch
nach Frankreich fahren die Grenze ist
nicht weit von hier und das machen wir
jetzt ich hatte Frankreich eh auf meinem
Plan dachte nur wegen der Verspätung
heute morgen dass ich das leider
ausfallren lassen muss weil ich sonst
nicht in die anderen Länder schaffe aber
irgendwie wird das jetzt glaube ich doch
klappen wir schauen mal am Ende okay
jetzt bin ich in H alsz noch nie davon
gehört aber sieht gar nicht mal so klein
aus und das Gute ist ich muss jetzt
ungefähr 500 m large
und dann bin ich in Frankreich Land 5
heute und dann machen wir mal ein
kleines Zwischenfazit und resume aber da
L jetzt erst mal im hin so Leute mal
ebenenso nach Frankreich laufen ist dann
halt doch nicht es war jetzt auf jeden
Fall doch ein Kilometer und ja hinter
mir ist eine Baustelle da vorne kann man
aber schon eine Brücke sehen und
dahinter ist Frankreich also einmal
wieder außenrum gerade wirklich fast
viermal überfahren
worden nur um nach scheiß Frankreich zu
kommen na vorne wer kann es denn schon
sehen ich dachte gerade wirklich kurz
die haben jetzt hier noch so eine
Stadtmauer und Frankreich ist dahinter
aber zum Glück nicht so die letzten
Meter Land Nummer
geschafft ich habe mir das hier zwar
irgendwie ein bisschen idyllischer alles
vorgestellt anstatt an so einer Straße
aber was willst du machen okay wir haben
jetzt mittlerweile 15:24 gerade kam auch
wieder die Meldung hallo du hast jetzt
ein neues Land erobert bin jetzt einfach
schon seit 9 Stunden 30 unter ich muss
sagen das ist echt schon eine ganz schön
lange Zeit W haben jetzt das fünfte Land
also wenn es so weitergeht würde ich ja
über zehn schaffen aber ich glaube das
wird eng ich muss jetzt den Weg weites
gehehen wieder zurück dass wir hier zum
Flughafen kommen nach Luxemburg der ist
30 km weg und von da aus geht's dann mit
Swiss Air erst in die Schweiz nach
Zürich und dann nach Wien am besten wäre
eigentlich ein Flug direkt in irgendwie
so ein Länder Dreieck Viereck wo so ganz
viele Länder direkt ineinander sind
gewesen aber Wien war irgendwie das
beste ich habe keinen besseren Flug
gefunden schauen wir mal ich halte mich
ran und wir sehen uns am Flughafen in
Luxemburg und Kanal abonnieren leute
wenn ihr die Videos feiert ich sag das
gerne einmal im Video meistens vergesse
ich es ist ein Klick kostenloses Abo da
lassen und wir gehen jetzt wieder
zurück so angekommen am Flughafen
Weihnachten wird hier auch schon
aufgebaut ja kann man eigentlich jetzt
machen ne 20 November Weihnachtsmärkte
gehen ja auch jetzt los ich freue mich
schon Flughafen sieht ganz nett aus
schön beleuchtet und ihr kennt mich
Leute jetzt geht's erstmal in der Lounge
so ab in der lookir
Lounge priity ja
[Musik]
so wie man sehen kann so langsam wird
schon dunkel im Dunkeln bin ich auch
gestartet aber der Tag ist noch lang
deswegen jetzt erstmal ein Kaffee oder
zwei perfekt Leute gerade die Nachricht
bekommen Flug verspätet draußen ist auch
gerade übelst am Regnen ich habe halt
nur dreivel Stunde umstiegszeit in Wien
und ich muss diesen Flug bekommen wenn
ich diesen Flug nicht bekomme dann bin
ich wirklich so sauer ne dann wäre der
Tag so gelaufen eigentlichil ich habe
mir als Ziel gesetzt eigentlich
mindestens a Länder zu schaffen und das
werde ich dann nicht packen 15 Minuten
Verspätung also alles noch gut natürlich
der letzte kann ich mir ein Platz
aussuchen also im Flugzeug ist auf jeden
Fall nicht viel los ich bin die ganze
Strecke auch schon mit dem Nachzug
gefahren das hätte ich theoretisch auch
machen können nur dann hätte ich auf
jeden Fall also dann hätte ich safe
nicht so viele Länder geschafft wie ich
es mir vorgenommen habe deswegen ist das
jetzt der einzige Flug also danach wird
das eh nichts mehr zeitlich wobei wir
machen jetzt Schweiz Österreich und dann
noch Slowenien und Ungarn wenn ich
schaffe angekommen in zürg am Flughafen
ich habe auch schon Boarding also der
Flug nach Wien ist schon zum Einsteigen
bereit aber das werde ich wohl packen
weil da waren ganz viele drin die dann
noch nach Bienen müssen also so langsam
habe ich echt keinen Bock mehr aber
nicht rummeckern weiter
geht's wir haben jetzt 22:10r und ich
bin angekommen in Wien ich habe übrigens
eben vergessen zu sagen das war Land
Nummer 6 also Zürich da war weicher WD
wahrscheinlich einfach reineditiert auf
jeden Fall jetzt in Wien D Nummer 7 aber
wir gehen mal kurz
raus jetzt ist das Ding ich muss mich
echt beeilen ich muss noch ein zukriegen
ins nächste Land mein Plan ist jetzt ich
will noch in die Slowakei nach
Bratislava das ist glaube ich am
nächsten und die einfachste connection
oder ich fahre mit uber das sind halt so
40 km ist auch so dumm aber geht
wahrscheinlich schneller weil ich will
auch gucken ob es danach noch weitergeht
es ist halt jetzt schon so spät hi kann
ich mit Karte bezahlen muss nach
Bratislava zum Bahnhof
alles fit bei dir auch danke wie lange
fährt man dahin 38 38 Minuten
[Musik]
okay rauchst du nee ich rauch nicht Zen
sind in Slowakei bestimm günstiger ne
wenn die di Sugar Free haben würde ich
das nehmen vielen Dank die Leute denen
ich heute begegnet bin waren echt alle
richtig korrekt also auch er jetzt hier
wieder sehr netter Typ ich befinde mich
jetzt auch tatsächlich schon in der
Slowakei wir sind jetzt gleich in
Bratislava war ich habe mich jetzt
einfach dazu entschieden komm wir machen
das mit Taxi online Standard Kost so 90
€ ich bin hier schon bei 138 oh mann ey
aber so habe ich halt die Hoffnung dass
ich wenigstens noch mit dem Zug
weiterkomme bis nach Ungarn z.B oder
vielleicht noch in irgendein anderes
Land weil wir haben jetzt 23 Uhr und ja
irgendwann fahren Hal keine Züge mehr
Taxi jetzt noch ich habe gerade überlegt
soll ich mit ihm einfach noch nach
Ungarn fahren aber das wird ja das wird
auch den Rahmen sprengen dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich am 300 € bezahlen und
habe dann noch ein Land mehr ich muss
sagen ich bin bis jetzt top zufrieden
ich hätte heute Mittag nicht gedacht
dass ich die achtländer wir voll bekomme
ich wün dir schönen ab wünsch dir auch
ber Mann Leute
Bratislava ich bin jetzt hier irgendwo
im
Zentrum Land Nummer 8 ach so hier ist
der Bahnhof was von wo komme ich denn
jetzt hier bitte also der fährt auf
jeden Fall schon mal nach Wien ach so
hier ist ein Gleis
ah aber ein komischer Bahnhof ne diger
ach du
scheiße wenn es geht bitte kurz nicht
losfahren macht man nicht nicht
nachmachen ich versue noch Land zu
kommen wenn ich jetzt hier einen Zug
bekomme werde ich den nehmen ansonsten
habe ich auch noch 200 € sixgut haben
für ein Mietwagen die Frage ist
natürlich bekomme ich hier irgendwo
jetzt noch ein Mietwagen weil neuen
Länder wärden schon geil ich glaube das
mit den Zügen sieht echt schlecht aus
was ist denn Deutsch Kreuz Wien wien
Wien ja kacke also nach Ungarn geht's
hier nicht mehr ich muss mal überlegen
Leute ich bin auch irgendwie so dumm ne
ich dachte mir jetzt okay ich springe
jetzt in diesen Zug nach Wien weil in
Wien wird's bestimmt noch eine
Autovermietung geben natürlich nicht die
haben alle zu und auf der anderen Seite
fühle ich mich gerade auch überhaupt
nicht als könnte ich noch 150 km Auto
fahren nur ich wäre jetzt viel lieber in
Bratislava geblieben weil ich da halt
noch nie war hätte ich mir morgen
anschauen können jetzt bin ich in diesem
scheiß Zug hier gefangen und komme auch
nicht mehr zurück nach Bratislava weil
das ist der letzte Zug bin wirklich
durch Leute ich gebe auf mehr wird nicht
es sei denn das passiert ein Wunder aber
aber ich glaube an Youtuber die ich
herausfordere also acht Länder sind
schlagbar das kann man schaffen und ich
habe so einen großen Hunger also meine
Fahrradreise war auf jeden Fall ein
hartes video das hier heute war auch
nicht ohne also schon anstrengend ich
bin mittlerweile schon so verstrahlt ich
habe einfach ein Hotel gebucht was 6 km
jetzt weg ist vom
Hauptbahnhof
hi
was Ciao ber fora Fahrer der hat sich
auch gefragt ob ich Hilfe brauche ich
sehe wahrscheinlich so aus mittlerweile
ich habe einfach bei Maps geguckt dann
war da halt so ein bahnhofszeichen und
dachte ja das wird schon der
Hauptbahnhof sein ich habe gar nicht
drüber nachgedacht ist einfach irgendein
Bahnhof jetzt habe ich 100 € bezahlt für
die Scheiße muss ich irgendwie hinkommen
mann Mann Mann kurz ein mal frisch
gemacht gerade im Hotel angekommen Alter
ich bin so verrckt ein bisschen ärgere
ich mich dass ich kein neunes Land
geschafft habe aber egal ihr könnt ja
gerne mal meine Leistung in den
Kommentaren bewerten bevor ich aber
schlafen gehe möchte ich noch meine
Herausforderer herausfordern h ich
erwarte natürlich von Keim dass er das
auch wirklich durchzieht also ich
verstehe dass das auch ein bisschen
crazy ist und ja aber mich wirürd es auf
jeden Fall super freuen und ich würde es
mir sehr gerne angucken ein bisschen mit
travel sollte man ja was zu tun haben
erstmal zelti kennt sicherlich viele von
euch macht coole Videos auch auf so
travel stuff ich hoffe du siehst das
falls nicht schicke ich dir nimm die
Challenge gerne an ich würde mich mega
freuen bin auch nicht sa wenn es nicht
passiert aber vielleicht topst Du mich
ja Franklin würde ich auch zutrauen dass
das umsetzt ich bin gespannt ich glaube
der hat jetzt erstmal so ein Boxkampf
aber vielleicht irgendwann danach also
falls Du das siehst ich fordere Dich
nicht im Boxkampf heraus sondern in der
Challenge wie viel Länder schafft man in
24 Stunden und jetzt bra ich noch einen
dritten dritte Person habe ich auch
gefunden ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
überlegen weil ich würde die Person auch
gerne so ein bisschen kennen zumindest
und es sie halt zutrau dass die Chance
besteht dass wirklich so ein Video
irgendwann kommt und zwar Levin ich
glaube der könnte das auch machen
zumindest hin und wieder was ich von dem
sehe wirk das ganz experimentierfudich
ansonsten falls ihr Youtube Videos macht
und euch denkt ey ich kann das auch ich
werde Alex schlagen macht es gerne
schickt mir dann das Video bei insta ich
werde das ziemlich sicher sehen ich
würde mich auf jeden Fall freuen weil
auf die Videos kann ich dann
gegebenfalls auch mal reagieren auf
meinem anderen Kanal wir haben jetzt
kurz vor zwe ich bin über 20 Stunden
wach und freue mich jetzt auf mein Bett
ihr habt heute natürlich nicht viel von
irgendwelchen Ländern oder Städten
gesehen ich weiß ich selber auch nicht
das war aber auch nicht die Idee oder
die Intention des Videos ach habe ich
geschafft danke fürs zuschauen Daumen
nach oben würde ich mich sehr drüber
freuen und wir sehen uns nächste Woche
wieder gibt's neues Video gute Nacht
Leute
ciao